un cielo teñido de gris la nueva
erupción del volcán la sufría en la isla
de san vicente y las granadinas expulsó
espesas capas de ceniza y humo causando
pánico entre los residentes locales sur
había claridad pero luego de luz comenzó
a deteriorarse y no fue a un ritmo lento
se estaba deteriorando rápidamente y sé
dónde está situado el volcán la cumbre
el cráter y no puedo distinguir lo era
solo oscuridad y luego lo que sucedía
era que empezabas a sentir algo en tu
piel ceniza la sufría que traduce salida
de azufre en francés tuvo este viernes
su primera erupción desde 1979 se estima
que las columnas de humo han alcanzado
al menos 15 kilómetros de altura las
cenizas que se extienden a más de 50
kilómetros de distancia por el mar
caribe han dificultado el traslado de
los damnificados a las zonas más seguras
y podrían afectar a las vecinas islas de
barbados santa lucia y granada
lo que es aterrador es que debajo de la
superficie hay mucha lava mucha roca
fundida hirviendo entonces lo espantoso
ahora es cuando expulsar a la lava
fundió
el primer ministro ralph gonsálves
informó que el proceso de evacuación se
está intensificando y que dos cruceros
llegaron para trasladar a las personas a
las islas vecinas a la operación se han
sumado otras líneas de cruceros la cifra
de evacuados no es precisa pero los
medios hablan de más de 20.000 los
expertos creen que las erupciones
podrían repetirse durante las próximas
horas y días